desde 2014 se autodenominan repúblicas
populares de done jet ski lugansk y con
apoyo ruso buscan mantenerse
independientes de ucrania en un
conflicto que ya se ha cobrado
aproximadamente 15 mil vidas
la república popular de done jets que
tiene más de 2 millones de habitantes la
de lugansk un millón y medio pero la
región conocida como el donbass se
extiende más allá de esta frontera
armada también llamada el cinturón de
óxido de ucrania se trata de un enclave
vital por su importancia minera e
industrial
rusia ha expedido unos 800 mil
pasaportes a ciudadanos de estas zonas
separatistas y reconoció este lunes su
independencia
creo que es necesario tomar una decisión
que ya estaba atrasada reconocer
inmediatamente la independencia y
soberanía de la república popular de
donges y la república popular de lugansk
pido a la asamblea federal de la
federación rusa apoyar esta decisión y
ratificar los tratados de amistad y
asistencia mutua con ambas repúblicas
ahora podrían convertirse en el
trampolín de vladimir putin en su
ofensiva militar sobre ucrania una
ofensiva militar que enfrenta una de las
principales potencias del mundo con una
república relativamente nueva el
presupuesto militar ucraniano supone
menos de un 10% del ruso russia tiene
cuatro veces más tropas y un equipo
terrestre marítimo y aéreo mucho más
extenso una amenaza difícil de ignorar